>>Tom: Today our activity will be you
all taking smaller congruent shapes
and building a larger similar shape.
>>Narrator: Teacher Tom Wolken worked
in the computer industry before
coming to teach seventh-grade math
at Olmsted North,
and the career-change
culture shock caused him
to be physically ill
and mentally stressed.
>>Tom: Within the first week that I
was here, I approached my principal,
Mr. Perkins, and I told him that
I was having a really bad day.
He said, "How bad could it get?"
I had described the worst
situation would be that I went back
to my former employer and they'd
already filled my position,
and I was jingling my car
keys as I said this to him.
So he said, "Well, we'll get you
some more help in your classroom.
You hang in there another week,"
and I did that and I've had --
every year since then it's
gotten better and better.
>>Guys, which of these
shapes can fit together
to make a larger shape that's
similar to the original?
>>Narrator: Now three years into the
job, Wolken's classroom is a hive
of active learning, partly because
he's learned some tricks of the trade
in dealing with Olmsted's
all-male environment.
>>Tom: In my three years of
teaching, I've only taught all boys,
so I like that energy
in the classroom.
>>You have 20 seconds
when I say "go"...
>>We can be more competitive.
Boys respond to a competitive
environment.
I'd like to tie my classroom
to a lot of things we do.
>>Joe, there's 19 seconds left.
We need to...
>>Boys respond to different colors
and sound cues than girls do,
so I try to use all that
in my classroom environment
to get my boys engaged
and keep them learning.
>>Divide up the work.
Have one person work on squares
and sketch it, one person work
on diamonds, one person
work on trapezoids...
>>I could've have done this
less than three years ago,
but I don't think the student
outcomes would've been as good.
I wouldn't have been cued
in to the boys' energy.
I probably would've stood and
lectured most of the time instead
of having them to hands-on
activities.
I probably would not have
given them as much structure.
Boys need structure.
>>Guys, 10 more seconds.
>>These are the outcomes
that we're expecting.
This is the time you
have to do it in.
You're going to have
time to work together.
Then you're going to have time
to listen to your instructor,
and during that time you'll
also be asking questions,
but we raise our hands.
We don't shout out.
So, I brought a lot of different
structure and energy to my classroom
that was not there three years ago.
>>Now, remember, let's think
about using our math words.
>>I created a PowerPoint
display to put
up a special message during the week.
It's usually an inspirational
message.
I also use the clock to show
pictures of the students doing things
that demonstrate school
spirit or having fun.
It's also classroom management,
because I'll tell my guys
that if they earn recognition
slips in my room
that I can put their picture and two
of their buddies on TV for a week,
and they get excited about that.
>>Quantel's going to show
us how he did a trapezoid.
>>I use the Web cam in my
classroom for two reasons.
First, the boys respond to be able
to show and demonstrate their work.
They take a great deal
of pride in that.
And, secondly, I use it as
a classroom-management tool.
I went out and spent $20.00
at the discount store.
The camera is mounted on
Popsicle sticks with duct tape,
and it gives the boys an area
where they can show their work.
>>So, Dwan created a larger
version of that triangle.
>>As far as classroom
management, I use the camera
because if the boys want to come
up and use it, they need to show me
that they've gotten their work done.
They need to have had appropriate
behavior during the lesson,
and then they're eligible to
come up and use the technology,
so it's not just a whiz-bang
feature in the classroom.
It's also for their
learning experience,
because if everybody's doing their
work, if everybody's being respectful
in the classroom, then
everybody can learn.
>>What was our scale factor
to go from one to two inches?
>>Student: Two.
>>Tom: Okay.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.